today this woman's known as rosie the
riveter her poster says we can do it
during World War two overall American
women's employment increased from 12
million in December 1941 to 16 million
in March 1944 it peaked at 19 million
that July more than 2 million women
started jobs in wartime manufacturing
specifically the stuff of riveting they
came from other industries housework in
school how did millions of women enter a
new industry in the span of a few years
here is the office of the supervisor of
women employee women of Steel changed
labor and helped win a war but how did
the country manage to transform a
massive war effort on the turn of a dime
how did all the women behind this image
become riveters
[Music]
with the army taking men by the
thousands more than 16,000 Hammar plants
so far we had to find people to replace
them a great untapped reserve was women
the Pearl Harbor attack effectively
launched the United States into World
War two the labor pool had to get bigger
quickly a group of women in government
wanted women to fill in the gaps in the
Department of Labor Frances Perkins was
the first female Secretary of Labor she
worked with Thelma McKelvey of women's
labor supply services she was part of
the war production board which managed
the conversion of peacetime industries
to meet wartime needs Mary Anderson was
the leader of the women's Bureau a
Department of Labor agency that
advocated for women's employment since
1920 they all worked with the war Maine
Power Commission a wartime agency that
had a women's Advisory Committee
including leaders across industries like
efficiency expert Lillian Gilbreth
lawyer Margaret Hickey and school
principal model booze field these groups
all helped shape public perception of
wartime women workers with ads in PR but
the most important process was practical
they had to help women find the
thousands of war industry jobs that
needed workers they did that through the
US Employment Service this pamphlet lays
out the steps women could take to find a
wartime job the office of War
Information distributed it to magazine
editors and the public government work
go to the civil service military work
insure stations through reserve like
waves industry find the US employment
service this agency became a subset of
the war manpower Commission the US
Employment Service coordinated local
offices which refer jobseekers to
employers who could offer war industry
work employers also recruited through
classified ads trade schools advertised
to men and women as well as the draft
further depleted the supply of mail
workers women filled a host of
industrial jobs from lathe work to
welding
one specific job was perfect for that
boom as early as May 1942
Thelma McKelvey said that four aircraft
jobs women riveters in particular would
be commonplace with the ever increasing
demand for greater speeds and aircraft
it has been necessary to remove every
possible projection from the outer
surface of the airplane industrial jobs
clustered around Detroit Baltimore and
Seattle with high aircraft and ship
production increases in women in
manufacturing in those cities were huge
especially for riveters learning how and
where to put four seven hundred thousand
rivets that go into a single Liberator
bomber to train an onslaught of
inexperienced labor employers develop
techniques some of them were likely
sexist
they were as fast as men they have not
bested four rivets are but the presence
of a bomber
to hold it together against the speed of
nearly three hundred and fifty miles an
hour
others sped up training for employees
who had to learn an entirely new job
really quickly women workers can be
surprisingly good producers you've got
to study every job and subdivide into
simple operating slips Mary Anderson of
the women's Bureau recommended riveting
which is the most common job throughout
assembly the women's Bureau recruited
for those jobs in ways that appealed to
contemporary notions of women's traits
riveting used a delicate touch
manipulative dexterity of a high degree
as well as extreme accuracy in
measurement teamwork could help with
training Rosalyn Palmer who inspired the
named Rosie the Riveter started out as a
Riveter but became a welder after she
was paired with a crackerjack welder who
taught me all he knew the training
showed results boeing seattle quadrupled
monthly output from 1942 to 1944 in
detroit worker hours per bomber dropped
at the ford willow
on bomber plant they went from 200,000
hours to less than 18,000 hours thanks
in part to increased efficiency from
subdividing jobs these riveters
succeeded in transforming the war effort
aimed the labor market Rosie the Riveter
is truth in myth look this pin we can do
it was a poster the Westinghouse
Electric Company made to briefly show at
its factories the real-life woman who
inspired her likeness was an Alameda
Naval Air Station employee named Naomi
Parker rosie became mythologized in a
Norman Rockwell painting a psalm and
even a movie shortly thereafter and the
Westinghouse poster became all but
ubiquitous when a copy was unearthed in
the 1980s but the truth about real
riveters was more complicated and it
didn't make the poster in 1942 Thelma
McKelvey of the war production board
testified that women were paid ten to
fifteen cents an hour lower despite
equal pay regulations results varied
wildly by company and region but during
the war some unions used claims of
seniority and job differentiation to
keep women's pay down they also pushed
for women to give back men's jobs when
the war was over I should say that when
my husband comes back I'm gonna be busy
at home good for you
what about after this warning well this
job belongs to some soldier when he
comes back he can help women of color
were also discriminated against in some
places black women in industry went from
6.5 percent to 18 percent during the war
but employers were spotty at Wagner
electric in st. Louis sixty-four percent
of employees were white women 24% black
males and 12% white males they simply
did not hire black women most women who
did work were already in the workforce
single and without children so it's easy
to overestimate how much the war changed
things
total working women also declined when
the war ended but World War two did
transform public and private sector
labor about half of the already employed
women switched employment from clerical
work to higher paying manufacturing work
and the number of employed married women
increased during and after the war the
real story of women riveters is more
complicated than a poster or a slogan
but together private industry women
leaders and all those working women
changed work in America one rivet at a
time
[Music]
you